the latest trailer for infinity war has
arrived and it's packed with even more
action than before with a ton of all-new
epic moments thundering across the
screen some less obvious details are
bound to slip through the cracks here
are the small details you may have
missed in the new infinity war trailer
half the universe while the first
trailer had Thanos waxing poetic about
his dream of balancing the universe it
was still pretty vague about just how he
intended to do that now Gamora spells
out for us exactly what he plans to do
he only ever had one goal to wipe out
half the universe if he gets all the
Infinity stones longtime comics readers
know what's up when Thanos assembled the
full power of the stones in the 1991
comic event Infinity Gauntlet his first
order of business was to make half of
all life in the universe suddenly
vanished without warning he did this in
order to impress Marvel's death who in
the comics is a sexy undead being he
would very much like the smoochy it
seems our heroes will have a bit more of
an advance warning in the movie but will
they be able to stop that oh s--- before
his fateful finger snap Loki's betrayal
in the last few minutes of Thor Ragnarok
Loki deftly lifted the tesseract
promotants treasure room as the Ascar d
ins journeyed into space away from the
ruins of their home Loki and Thor seemed
to at last truly make amends or did they
the new infinity war trailer finds the
god of mischief seemingly ready to
surrender the tesseract willingly the so
called space stone is likely what will
allow the mad Titan to warp to earth
what's Loki's endgame it's impossible to
guess considering he has a penchant for
double triple and quadruple crosses
surprise new order the black order is
Thanos's elite squad of lieutenants
charged with doing the kind of nitty
gritty dirty work he wouldn't touch with
a ten-foot Infinity Gauntlet their
on-screen incarnation includes
strategist Corvus glaive Proxima
midnight
the massive cull obsidian and the
slippery Evan Imam while we can only
glimpse the assembled group briefly in
the trailer every mall gets special
attention he may be in the midst of
manipulating the power of dr. strange to
facilitate Thanos invasion which is
something he's done before in the comics
tiny Gamora the two guardians of the
galaxy movies have built an epic
backstory a family drama behind Thanos
and his daughters Gamora and nebula it's
a bitter tale of abuse betrayal and
attempted murder the new infinity war
trailer provides a surprising moment of
family bonding we see fan OHS take a
tiny green hand in his giant purple one
as he walks with a young girl toward an
ornate archway it seems like a safe bet
that the girl is a young Gamora
but is this a flashback maybe some
weirdness via the Infinity stones
Thanos gets his helmet since his first
appearance during the end credits of the
Avengers Thanos's look has been tweaked
but he remains instantly recognizable
but when the first infinity war trailer
hit many comic book fans were plagued
with one question
where's his helmet something about that
big bald head just felt wrong
fortunately the new trailer shows off
multiple shots that find his shiny hat
firmly in place or freshly removed
where's Hawkeye Marvel is touting
infinity war as the culmination of the
entire Marvel Cinematic Universe
providing a grand clash of as many
heroes and villains as can fit into two
and a half hours of IMAX sized action I
know all your names
the new trailer includes just about all
of our leading stars but one of the
original Avengers is still conspicuously
missing Jeremy Renner is confirmed to be
back once more as Clint Barton aka
Hawkeye but none of infinity wars
marketing has shown even a single one of
Hawkeye's mighty purple feathers it
would be strange if this founding member
of the cinematic Avengers didn't have a
major role to play in this big payoff
directors Joe and Anthony Russo remained
tight-lipped on the subject of Clint
hinting only that he has a special spot
in the film let's hope he actually stays
alive and doesn't get well shafted
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]